so
hi i'm julia sandrini i work for the
image processing team
part of the bigger sound and vision team
at wolfram
and i deal mainly with image color
processing both classical and
machine learning neural network based
and this talk is about
the latter of course so first i
i would like to set some
naming straight because what i was
preparing for for this i
i noticed that uh there were a lot of
names
and uh that may be confusing for the
same thing
so i i decided to put this uh this
little piece of dictionary at the
beginning and
which helps me clarify what we're going
to talk about today so
many of you might be familiar with image
classification
which is basically the task of
identifying the main object in the
picture
uh it's a kind of solved problem quote
unquote in
in computer vision now like neural
networks are performing very well on
these they can be very accurate
and and also reasonably fast
a closely related task is uh object
recognition
which apparently is just
like this kind of common assumed
definitions but it's not so important
right now i would say but the
point is that there may be pictures like
this where you have more than one
objects and
you you want to be aware of that you
want to realize that
this is the thing then a bit more
towards the goal of this talk
we have localization that means that we
want to produce
bounding boxes for all the
interesting relevant i mean depends on
the application objects in a picture
and then finally combining the last two
step there's
and here the definition is a bit more
agreed upon object detection which is
the
purpose of this of this talk so idea
here that
i have an arbitrary picture and i want
to provide
both localization and classification for
each object
and usually i also want to have a
measure of
the accuracy or confidence in in this
how confident the detector is
at this prediction so how does this
whole thing work
typically you have you have three steps
in the
detection pipeline uh also stop me uh i
mean stop me you can write at any point
if your questions i'm i'm trying to
monitor the the the chart while i'm
speaking so
don't don't feel that you have to wait
till the end
okay so the idea is that we want a piece
of of software that will
uh propose some region of the image
then i want we want to convert these
pixels
into some sort of computable um
feature vector typically the itt is a
vector features but the idea is that we
go to a tensor that
represents uh semantically what the
content of this piece of image is
and at the end we want to take this and
produce a classification
so like for example this one doesn't
contain anything
so what was the the typical way to do
this before neural network i'm going to
be
very fast on this uh
the idea is that one one basic thing is
like why don't exhaust all possible
regions so you do something like this
you you you slide and the the region
proposal step is basically sliding a
window across the image
and you can do it you can do it on any
image pyramid for example
so multiscale this is like like making
the window bigger or smaller
and this will allow you to produce
candidates for theoretically all
possible regions you can vary aspect
ratio too
and this is a bit inefficient because it
creates a lot of
boxes a lot of proposals so kind of a
state of the art in in classical image
processing before
deep learning was an approach called
selective search
uh or like similar approaches the idea
is that you want to do a core
segmentation
and then uh with the caveat that you
don't want to split objects
uh sorry you want obviously you don't
want to
to have one one uh patch that spans
multiple objects
and then you combine them to to have
some sort of region proposal at
all possible states and this will create
basically
what you want to send to your feature
extractor so what are the feature
extractors
before deep learning you had all sort of
hand-picked
features one of the most famous is like
hard like features named after the
wavelets the idea here is that you want
to
[Music]
for example in this case you want to
subtract the pixel in the black
area to the pixel in the white area
re-normalize and have sort of
an idea of what's going on in in a
region combined paired with the shape of
the region
so the idea that you would be able to
for example here find eyes and nose
uh given enough descriptors uh other
things you can do
you can do local binary patterns or you
can do
the formal parts like this use histogram
oriented gradients the the
idea of all this is that you want to
split uh
your your candidate box
uh into sub boxes measure some property
do a histogram and then send that to a
classifier like
support vector machine or something else
as you can imagine this
has all sort of problems
given the huge variability of pose
rotation orientation of natural
objects in images and this was setting a
hard
upper bound on the accuracy of this
classifier
so with the advent of new letters people
started
thinking why not why can i mean this
stuff is performing very well we should
actually use it
for detection so one of the
first of the of these steps is this
rcnn net uh that basically
uses a standard region proposal with the
selective search what i showed before
but instead of using
uh classical image processing features
based on filters or
[Music]
whatnot it it sends
the part of the image to a convolutional
neural net which is creating the feature
vector itself
after that the feature vector is sent to
a standard classifier like again this i
think this model was using uh single
support versus machines
so you have like one one step replaced
with the with the your net
i mean you do one why not uh not two so
um there was uh
some sometimes after this second couple
of years after uh
a new model called fast
rcnn because it was also faster that was
only keeping the first
[Music]
region proposal part with classical
image processing
and the rest was basically fully
convolutional uh
fully neural net let's say pipeline so
you have uh
you send the proposed uh image part to
the to the feature instructor and then
you use these
features to compute probabilities of
classes and to
regress the the correct boundaries for
the bounding box
i mean we've done two out of three of
course you can imagine that the final
step was to do three out of three
and uh so shortly after this
this other paper came out which is
faster rcnn
that is uh making use of the
fully convolutional fully fully internet
pipeline i think this is maybe even
fully convolutional
and the point here is that you use the
convolutional feature structure itself
and the map that it produces
to uh to run a small network that is
proposing bounding boxes
based on the features and then you send
back those bounding boxes
and use them to to mask this roy pooling
stage is used to
to to pull out regions from the feature
map and then you slide
this is this one it's called two stage
detectors because this is one
net and then you have a second net which
is this one which has two two heads
which is pretty
predicts similar to the one before
predicts uh um
scores and for glasses and coordinates
and this level is light so it's a map
operation if you're familiar with
mathematica
on the um on the region proposed by the
the region proposal network
here in this image you see also one term
which will
appear again which is anchor boxes what
does it mean
so the idea is that you are typically
always better off
having the network do the easiest job
possible if you want
like fast convergence high accuracy so
the thing is
uh real objects as i said come in all
sort of scales and
aspect ratios so the idea here was why
don't we help the network why don't we
instead of asking the
this these two this has here actually to
to predict uh
the right center and the right with and
the right height for for each object
starting from no no prior assumption why
don't we just
uh maybe tell the network where the
center was like starting from which
i mean the the sliding window where it
was and uh
also we give in this case k five six
seven
nine uh priors on scale you see this is
small scale
this one here is bigger scale these are
two different aspect ratios
so basically the idea is that if these
are picked well enough
uh at least one of those will be very
close or closer
to what the actual scaling aspect ratio
my object is and the network will have
an easier job
refining a good good coordinates so
this is kind of a has been a very
relevant and today still is a relevant
step um okay a lot of people are not
super happy with this uh
uh two stage detectors so there was a
lot of research
into like how do we make it uh i was
even possible to make a single stage
and for a long time the answer was yes
but not with the same
accuracy so you have the detectors that
then
basically in one swoop they predict uh
features and then they use those
features to predict like not really
dense yeah dense it's a dense uh
set of like you can imagine basically
each one of these grids
in these cells contains predictions and
so you're not sliding anything the the
whole thing is the end of the
convolution pipeline
and you can just look at that with what
they are and rescale accordingly
so this is faster because it doesn't
depend on the number of boxes
the the previous one had to slide but
was always suffering
in terms of in terms of accuracy so
[Music]
you have a lot of you can see a lot of
research into this like this is um
one network by google and uh and you see
that the
the the idea here is to
leverage more and more information in
order to make these detectors more and
more accurate for example this one here
uh i don't know if people know about
this kind of
model not a lot of people know about
deep learning here so maybe i have to
explain
the the idea here is that you you put
the image in
and the image gets through a lot of
filters that make it progressively
smaller and smaller
and you read this going up
and they encode the information in the
channel space
so at each time you see this is the the
size of the image is getting smaller
and the number of channels or these
images are getting bigger
you can eventually i mean in a
classifier you go to a one by one image
with all the information in the channel
space but here
uh you just want to stay here so this
then
you you you can have these multi-scale
predictions
and they were pretty accurate
uh one last step i don't want to spend
too much time here is like to get rid of
the anchors
so there are models that are trying us
to do that to get rid of this last final
step of
uh prior knowledge in in the models so
okay
we don't have much time so let's let's
have a look at how
we can go from this kind of data to this
kind of result so let me tell you
first bad news this stuff is not in 12.2
i mean let's be clear my own functions
that i'm going to use here are not in
4.2
but good news all the pieces that i'm
using are in 12.2
so if you want to put up with the work
this stuff is trainable today i mean
today if you have a
developer build is streamable today okay
this out of the other way let's see
um what we can do so i went online
and i pick uh from kaggle one
simple fruit image detector so it looks
like this you have test training folder
uh images for i think three
types of fruits and then xml files that
contain the metadata for the
detection so the idea here is that we
want to
let's see here we have like a bunch of
uh yeah these xml files they are
saved with the pascal block format which
is looks like this
so this basically is annotation i have
my image
[Music]
some metadata it contains an apple and
this is a bounding box
but of course i wasn't using that before
and the idea here is that
we want to
to parse this and i can probably provide
attendees if
you if you're interested in this i can
provide you with these functions later
and this basically is used to parse
this book um xml files into something
usable by the wolfram language
so we can do this for the training set
so we can do this for the test set
and uh basically then we have taken care
of the data part
so then here now we need
we need to to extract these features we
said we want convolutional networks to
extract features from these
images in order to produce boxes and
probabilities
so here are a bunch of choices for for
this talk
i wanted to start simple so i said like
let's try to do something which is
doable entirely on my uh puny laptop
so here i'm defining like if if you i
mean i don't want to explain this stuff
too much because there are plenty of
talks
in pasta conference that are available
the idea here is that you want to define
blocks that perform convolutional
operations and
you use residual blocks you may use
squeeze and excitation block to
basically recombine channel information
they're all sort of of goodies that you
can you can do
and then you want to
put them together in internet
that will perform this video instruction
one by one so this is a network that
ends in
in some um some classification but you
can always repurpose it for for
detection
so the idea here is that
we take this network and then we
we we want to attach
basically some layers at the end that
will make it easy
easy to to read the classification
information so here i wrote some
functions that basically does the job
for you and
then it attaches um
layers for the yolo architecture and you
just have to specify a bunch of
parameters and
i don't think it scales very well here
but it
takes the features and adds layers to
automatically compute the parameters
needed to
to regress classes and bounding boxes
and then the the big thing that the big
news is now
our framework as is is pretty much
very very uh uh
pretty much evolved in the last version
is very solid and it's very very easy to
perform all sort of array operations on
this
much easier than before so i was able to
easily write
losses for a bunch of functions like
centernet yolo
and i'm writing for more so the idea is
that this is a very
complex loss and you can see you want to
get you get inside you have pcs you have
interface
section of the union they like you you
don't want to waste too much time into
this
and i just want to spend one minute
actually
a shout out to the neolithic team that
made this possible and i'm sure that
people probably jerome are presenting
this but this is a
neat piece of functionality in 12.2 and
it basically allows you to take like
this layer for example here
i wrote it to do the intersection of a
union of two
boxes with the same center and this is a
mathematical function
that you can just apply and the idea is
that now i can just take this function
and put it in the function layer and
this will produce something
that i can then use in uh this is
basically a small parser that takes
top-level code and when possible it it
converts it
to uh neurological primitives
and the together with this came a lot of
improvements that
made the whole thing possible so the
idea is then
uh not much more actually so
you take the old faithfulness train you
put our through training set
you put the loss function the test set
this i can
oh what am i doing here
let's do this i probably okay i probably
don't want to to train this
real time this is a couple of minutes
like i just trained this before before
the
thing you see okay 1.3 minutes i i
trained this before before this talk
and oh yes there's a question i will put
this notebook in the
in the file section okay so you can
do object actually in one minute is it
solved
uh not really so like uh it's not as
simple as i'm showing this now if we i
mean we can take this and
i wrote some more utility functions to
uh
just save up the hassle of doing post
processing but then we can just apply it
and you see that
[Music]
not really good i mean this is a banana
caesar to apples let's try another image
okay this is an apple so i mean it was
going somewhere
he is finding some apples not all of
them
so i mean it definitely learns something
but this is not the type of problem that
you can stop in one minute
so i mean the setup was was was all
there so
what what can you do to make this better
the the thing is many things actually
first you don't want to use a model that
runs
in one minute on the laptop
unfortunately this
problem is still pretty hard so
you want deeper models uh some
architecture at the beginning
efficient at resnext resnet
uh i put this here so you can you can
have a look some of them are
already in the repository but um more
about that later
so you you want a um model with capacity
so a model that is enough parameters to
accommodate this task
you probably want to use multi-scale
detector which i didn't use for this
short training
here you had small apples big apples
this stuff is never going to work there
and the very important thing
a lot of detection data sets are small
is difficult to get this data i mean
small
small compared to the task that that you
want to solve
so you absolutely want to do what is
called that augmentation
so you want to generate more synthetic
data
from your detection data this is also
possible
of course in the world from language you
have wonderful uh image processing
capabilities
and here i'm using one function to make
it a bit easier that is doing some flips
rotation shifts
adding noise and the idea is that you
want something like this yes if this is
more noise
or slight rotation or
let's see if i find one
hmm come on it's 50 yeah here a flip so
all these are new images
that generate more data that you can use
for your training and some of these are
quite fast you can use them online
some arguments like if the if you want
to do
compose images you want to change the
the white point i mean this can
can add accuracy but uh maybe expensive
so you may want to pre-process your your
data before before the training
and so i say i run a bunch of these
things
and i still still i wanted something
that
was trainable on a laptop and then i
created another another director
that was trained in
half an hour on this laptop
still not perfect but you see i can i
can see which
much more that banana was picked by both
apples people both
uh the the reason why these bunnies are
not stretching is that really you need
much much bigger network that i can wrap
on my laptop so okay okay for example
this one here this is not picked up even
even after half an hour of training
just to give you a comparison of this
the the amount of time that you need
uh there are series detectors that are
trained a couple of days on multiple
gpus
so again not a laptop problem uh what
happens if we take one of those networks
so this network here has never seen the
image but you can see that
it has no problem indetecting that and
indetecting multiple multiple fruits at
the same time
so the thing is this is a problem that
can be solved
it requires a little bit of care and
right tools and uh we are now working
hard to make these tools
available in the easiest possible way so
i don't know if we have little time to
measure performance maybe maybe not
let's talk about this a bit uh because
it's more interesting
so the the idea here is that uh this is
a functionality that is coming
as i showed you know this i wasn't using
anything secret to put together this
talk
this stuff is all in in 12.2 um
what i would like to add is a lot
ton of uh quality of improvements
that will make this process much simpler
for the end user and for data parsing
data augmentation
defining all sort of loss measuring
performance
and the other the other piece here
is that you always want to step
on shoulders of giants you always want
to leverage
all the time it was spent in put
together big data sets and training
for example classification models and
to do this we are constantly adding
these models to the internet repository
and if i can click on this
oh yeah it's open the other way so
uh let me go
out of full screen here so we can see it
and um
where is firefox
okay cannot find it on this screen
oh it's still on the other screen here
it is
so this is a neural repository modules
like
efficient that are coming and you can
see if you go on classification
you can take
some of these like squeeze extension you
have mobile net
and you can repurpose them very easily
for for detection
um another thing that i would really
like to have is uh
still still in the easy views uh
direction
but uh to make both these instruments
available
individually and in a nice package so my
dream is that one day
we'll be able to have something like
this work and that these days not too
far
away in the future so we are really
closing here so
thank you for your attention and let me
know in the chat
if you have questions
i put the file in the in the file tab
and click it up a bit
thank you very much to everybody i'll be
available if you even if you have
questions
beyond this slot so just let me know
bye-bye and enjoy the conference